quand on connait au south on vous
connaît au sein vous ça va
mais la réunion la nation une heure
suffit pour se retrouver dans le sud de
madagascar un pays prioritaire de la
politique de coopération du département
madagascar n'est pas la même échelle que
la réunion 27 millions d'habitants quand
la réunion ne compte que neuf cent mille
habitants une grande île de 580 7295
kilomètres carrés avec 94% de la
population qui travaille dans une
économie informelle
la réunion s'est aussi 150000 personnes
qui attendent un emploi dont 53 mille de
moins de 30 ans
le décor est posé de part et d'autre les
besoins existent ainsi par le prisme de
l'appui à la francophonie le département
prend l'initiative
avec des cadres d'intervention
professionnelle des agents du
département relais de cette politique
volontariste
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
une petite salle dans un lycée public de
tuléar bienvenue au club de français
héloïse et karim sont en contrat unique
d'insertion avec le département en
lançant ça va mais c'est très différent
de la paix à l'arrêt parce que ben les
moyens ne sont pas les mêmes et même au
niveau de la nourriture là c'est pas les
mêmes
le climat ou si ce n'est pas le mec
arrive à un moment déjà tu que ton pays
tu quittes tout ça tu fais un break de
m'enrichir parce que c'est un concept
nouveau
je leur apprends vraiment quelque chose
quoi que ce soit tu leur apprend que ce
soit des la langue française la langue
créole l'histoire de chez nous des
conseils dans la vie d avant leur départ
ils ont bénéficié d'une formation au cio
paix du tampon tout comme leur référente
malgache qui est maintenant mettre
formatrice grâce à ce dispositif du
département c'est un autre en région sud
ouest 1 dont les français noirs un way
pratiquer quoi donc j'aimerais bien que
ça compte riscal offert la collaboration
français et je ne m'aurait bien aussi
quelle formation des enseignants ont
continué et demande la raison donc je
retiens que tous les posters de france
et massifs soient formés ou la réunion
france de l'océan indien
voilà l'opportunité encore faut-il
exister pour ses 27 millions d'habitants
est ce qu'il ya des fous à la réunion
mayotte comme ils sont tout près de nous
ils connaissent pas forcément à nous les
réunionnais on existe on pourra mieux se
comprendre
moi aussi j'ai envie de parler quelques
mots ou la langue malgache aussi puisque
plus on échangera plus indianocéanique
s'agrandira c'est une grande grande
famille de série nous reprenons la route
le long de cette magnifique plage de
l'océan indien où le temps s'est arrêté
ici le département accompagne ong bel
avenir à travers un programme de lutte
contre la malnutrition mais aussi avec
un poste de service civique
[Applaudissements]
le service civique je trouve que c'est
une occasion assez rêver surtout en tant
que réunionnais de découvrir une partie
du monde professionnel tout en ayant un
très bon suivi parce qu'on est quand ils
étaient encadrés par le département par
france volontaire de prendre une année
douze mois huit mois dans sa vie est de
rendre service à la france à la réunion
et par la même occasion développé des
choses comme la coopération régionale
les échanges culturels la préservation
de la biodiversité ou l'étendue de leur
rayonnement de la langue française
et puis mettre en commun nos savoir
faire tant sur l'agriculture que sur les
valeurs ajoutées faire en sorte que
l'anticipation soit commune aujourd'hui
la réunion et savoir-faire en forêt
stations sur les forêts semi sèche nous
partagerons du technicien nous
partagerons aussi leur savoir faire
aussi parce qu'ils ont un excellent
savoir-faire et puis pouvoir
démultiplier l'ol j'ai aujourd'hui qui
est la première et la seule ong avec
lesquels nous travaillons à madagascar
est et celle qui sera sur un projet
pilote
toutes ces situations vécues font
grandir l'âme et l'esprit de ces jeunes
à manille
direction tananarive ou la mission se
termine site ici qu'habitent melvin
comme un poisson dans l'eau
[Musique]
ça va bien j'adore j'adore la vie ici
atteint à ses superbes
là on est au lycée jules ferry et un
très beau bâtiment
ce que j'ai appris ici ben c'est déjà
l'autonomie plus d'autonomie plus de
sérieux plus de
de maîtrise de soi fouet meiway maîtrise
de soi et savoir parler enfin savoir
animer une classe déjà ça c'est
compliqué de base dans la provoc ou de
choses ici
j'espère qu'un employeur verra ça comme
ça quoi en projet mobilité n'est pas
fait que pour les ja puisque j'en suis
la preuve vivante
je leur franchement je les encourage
très très fortement à postuler pour
découvrir un nouveau mode de vie pour
découvrir une autre façon de voir les
choses et pour s'enrichir et enrichir
les autres également
ce jour là une partie des réunionnais en
poste à madagascar avait rendez vous
avec daniel gonthier ainsi que le
conseiller de coopération et d'action
culturelle de l'ambassade de france
parce que les personnes qui sont ici
interviennent dans des lycées dans le
cadre de notre projet dead à la
redynamisation du français je félicite
les élus de la réunion d'avoir eu cette
idée parce que ces jeunes là c'est ce
sont des passerelles entre la france et
madagascar antananarivo est un peu
l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est qu'ici
on parle relativement bien le français
mais dès qu'on s'éloigne
le français a perdu beaucoup
de sa prestance il faut reconquérir
certains publics puisque le français il
manque de l'emploi madagascar et parmi
le groupe de réunionnais yoann a une
grosse expérience de la coopération
internationale tout cela tisse son
avenir professionnel en tant que
réunionnais en fait il ya toujours cette
étape de la métropole et de paris en
fait qui intervient cependant après nos
études dont j'ai travaillé quelques
années à paris et je suis persuadé d'une
chose aujourd'hui c'est que si j'étais
resté à paris dans mon milieu
professionnel
j'aurais certainement pris beaucoup plus
de temps en fait à acquérir l'expérience
professionnelle que j'ai aujourd'hui
en fait est que j'ai acquise en fait
justement dans ce programme de mobilité
ceux tenus par la réunion donc revenir à
la réunion pour partir à l'international
en fait ça a été un choix bénéfique en
fait est payant
aucun regret la scion aujourd'hui notre
but c'est d'être terre de france avec
des savoirs réunionnais ça veut dire que
lorsque la francophonie cherche un
opérateur temps les indiens il ne va pas
appeler paris nous souhaitons qu'ils
appellent la rue et à partir de là remet
chaque chose à sa place on remet chaque
individu de la réunion acteur aussi de
son destin mais de son dessin à
l'intérieur de lyndiane ciani à
l'intérieur de l'encens de l'os indien
il se passe clairement quelque chose
d'incroyable dans ses missions
professionnelles le contexte malgache a
bousculé leurs cadres à savoir
d'expérience qui est une force
à condition d'y croire c'est une
ouverture par ce que pense que ça
s'arrête là mais moi j'ai découvert une
passerelle au niveau de la fin contre
les possibles
pas moi mais seul havre c'est à moi de
faire le nécessaire
chaque voyage est unique et on
s'enrichit en allant en allemagne mais
on s'enrichit mais pas de la même
manière qu'à madagascar
c'est quand même quelque chose d'un peu
plus
[Musique]
i